[Music]
[Music]
the present situation generally looks
like this the in many ways as I really
indicated last time the economy is very
strong it is very productive
productivity has grown rapidly and at
the present time the all the major
pulled the major troubles of Italy have
in fact been fixed now if you remember I
mentioned the following problems I
mentioned and I've mentioned inflation
unemployment deficits in the balance of
payment government deficit corrupt
government and bad government the only
one of this problem that has not yet
been fixed is unemployment the others
have been text but people don't
understand that and therefore they
haven't been fixed now specifically what
has not been fixed according to the way
people look at it is the deficit the
Italian deficit according to the latest
program which was adopted financial
program which was adopted earlier this
year the in the current deficit is
somewhere above 7 percent of GNP of GDP
and its program hopefully to come down
but slowly so that by 1990 6 or 7 it
would still be in the order of four
percent three and a half something like
that
and that means that in terms of this
program and these videos Italy could not
possibly enter
Master each in time because master itch
has certain parameters certain
requirements the deficit must be less
than 3% the inflation must be not more
than I guess has no more than some small
number above the lowest inflation's so
you look at the lowest and you cannot be
higher than some fraction of that the
three lowest I think similarly for
interest rates you cannot be more than
some margin above the three lowest
interest rates and the and these are the
only parameters because as we know maths
which parameters do not include the one
the only one that should really be there
a solution and I agree there is there
should be a parameter for unemployment
you should not enter if your
unemployment is more than five percent
okay but that parameter does not enter
message only the only thing that matter
is inflation and employment
no one cares no problem not no no German
problem it is of course now and but
still they insist that they don't care
the central bank policy can only be
directed toward keeping down inflation
no other thick merits so of course
unemployment is also high so that even
by that standard easily could net but it
could not enter on anyone and of course
the remaining requirement is that the
deficit be less than sixty percent of
GNP 50% or 60% or Jinping in Italy that
ratio is one of the quarter so we avenge
now essentially the key point is that
the reason why seems to be so far away I
mean the key parameter than this is the
government deficit okay the
percent deficit as against a 3%
requirement so that if you now ask in
Italy what are you going to do about it
you have two lines of decline wine is we
just cannot meet mass which will not
enter message will be second in the
class and will enter later God knows
when Gordon was win because if you don't
enter that makes the problem of entering
more difficult because then the change
rate will be unstable and interest rates
will be high and with high interest
rates the deficit will keep being high
so a major problem is the deficit and
that high deficit is purely fictitious
it's not there it's because the official
way you are calculating the deficit by
German dictate the Germans are the
powerful no matter how stupid they are
whatever they say is it a German dictate
you must know anything about a inclusion
accounting you must not know that when
you have inflation they will calculate
the burden of the debt is to include and
say an income they gain you make because
as a debtor your debt loses value okay
that is exactly an income that offsets
the high price you pay for interest when
there is inflation interest rates go up
because the terrans lose the inflation
therefore they get that much more okay I
mean the creditor lose they to the
extent of inflation therefore interest
rates go up to compensate for the fact
that they are losing so if they were
gaining 5% and now there is ten percent
deflation they get 15 percent of which
10 percent compensates for the inflation
loss and their left would fight but
thank the government that's been fine
you should agree that of that 15 rupees
10 is made up by the fact that it has
an income which corresponds to the loss
of the whole bus the loss of the whole
that is the gain of the government okay
you must taken into account in the
government budget and it is not
therefore it appears they have the huge
deficit now correcting for inflation
means you should subtract from the
deficit the product of the inclusion
times the size of the debt but if you
won't look at the deficit income ratio
then you must take the rate of inflation
and multiplied by the ratio of the
deficit debt to income the deficit we
the debt to Ingleside so at the present
time inflation is approximately I think
the last figures are abound for but has
been around five the last thing is for
only half four and a half yes four point
point five yes
spin around five interest rates
therefore are essentially nine and a
half when in Germany they are below for
the difference is first of all the
inclusion and then a little more than
that because of the exchange risk okay
which adds some additional point which
would disappear if you would enter
message because then there is no more
exchange risk because then your exchange
is fixed okay and presumably the
countries will help each other to
maintain exchange risk to I mean to
attain the changes so if you figure
things right Italy is the one the only
country now that has zero deficit the
only country okay and that this is not a
fiction can be seen in another way by
looking at the so called primary surplus
which is the the difference
okay it's that part of the of the
government earnings of the government
receipts above the payment of interest
that was take out of the government
budget the payment of interest and then
you will find that in Italy there is a
surplus of 30% that is currently seeds
exceed current expenditure without
interest of 30% which no other country
in Europe gets even closer okay
even though their real rates may not be
very different from Italy so Italy
already has made the gigantic effort by
creating this enormous primary surplus
and with that enormous primary circus it
can very easily pay the interest the
real interest and still have a balanced
budget in fact it already has the
balanced budget and is the only country
in Europe that in fact has a balanced
budget okay the other countries having
created the primary surplus that
necessary so all of them are behind
Italy in this respect but they don't
recognize it because they don't know how
to calculate ah I have been telling
Italians Germans and all the rest how to
compute the deficit when there is
inflation okay and I've been citing
texts and sources not my invention
anybody that studies inflation
accounting knows that there is the first
principle there are five or six major
biases that inflation produces in the
count okay
like the placement cost instead of
original cost which tends like surgery
profits and the treatment of inventories
which also try to generate profit and so
on and one of the major ones is
precisely effected the debt the interest
that you should apply to that is
not the nominal interest rate but the
real interest rate that is nominal minus
inflation now yes I mean in other words
they don't understand that you have to
adjust the deficit for the inflation for
what you gain from inflation all right
why do they make such a mistake but no
no I mean right now I think there's a
combination of reasons okay one reason
and one reason is simply ignorance
okay people do not understand the simple
reasoning okay and the ignorance is not
just limited to the chancellor of
germany it's widespread even among the
Italian public you are familiar with the
fact that people in Italy have
complained bitterly when during the
champion things were going well
inflation and I show you a graph came
down with accuracy in a very short time
interest rates came down and people were
complaining like mad I used to get 12%
now all I can get is 5 or 7 the fact
that there was no inflation didn't
matter okay
and fundamentally that is because of a
very deep misconception see people don't
understand this phenomenon okay let me
just cite you here one thing it's
fascinating generally there is a great
contrast between economists and the
public the common man he can't really
say inflation makes no difference okay
because everything moves together and so
it makes no difference are you late
in fact it does make a substantial
difference but it's a secondary order of
different okay is that prices get online
that certain things lag behind that you
know usual sorry that everything cannot
move together because you cannot change
the coin that you put into the parking
machine okay so the parking machine is
now for five cents and even though the
prices have doubled or treble you still
are not going to change it okay so it is
not true this is the trivial example but
there are many more example like taxes
and so on that are not adjusted
appropriately similarly you are taxed on
nominal interest rate no country yet
taxes on real interest rates which is
the only reasonable thing okay so that
you end up by taxing over a hundred
percent if you do things correctly you
will find that the tax is more than the
real interest you earn so in real terms
you end up with less money then you
start it up even though you get some
interest okay you can see that if you
get ten percent interest but inflation
is fifteen then they tend you've got
ninety five dollars per hundred dollars
in your hand but you get taxed as though
you were earning 15 now so in general
people don't understand it a very great
example of not understanding is a recent
survey that was made by one of my
students one of my by now of course more
important and I professor here and among
belongs to the large class of student of
mine who have done a better than I have
however he conducted a survey in various
countries including United States and
including Brazil asking people whether
they thought that wages kept up with
inflation in the remarkable result is
that people said of course
not and they asked him how long do you
think it takes before they catch up and
very few said Oh a quarter mostly said a
year or two son said never even in
Brazil where we just have you know the
inflation was so high then wages were
keeping up instantaneously practically
okay they better do that because when
inflation is 300 percent per year or
more if they don't keep up
you've nothing left nothing so people
don't understand that in fact wages the
experience is very clear we just follow
inflation very closely inflation doesn't
really affect their wages except
occasionally in some transient period
and so on but by-and-large
lien wages are not affected by inflation
you see the reason why people think it's
so terrible it's the following I mean I
think there is evidence of this they
think that when prices go up and they
get higher wages they think they get
higher wages because they are worth more
so the increase in salary is the
recognition is a real increase is a
recognition that they're worth more but
then those Darin merchants take
advantage of the fact that I deserve
more in the raise prices and they take
away what I have earned so its inflation
is all due to this bassant
who take advantage to these prices and
therefore it's not true that my wages
keep up with prices my wages keep up
with my work and prices just take away
what I deserved
now he when you start from this
mentality even mr. cold is probably not
very different from these people I don't
even know him personally so I don't know
but you know it's very easy not to
understand and on top of that the
Bundesbank
which you think is intelligent enough to
understand has a different reasoning it
says that if inflation makes you a Perea
because of the deficit good inflation is
the best thing and anything that makes
it bad is a good thing
okay so if by not understanding how to
compute it makes look like you have a
large deficit
the answer is stop inclusion don't
calculate the deficit correctly stop
inclusion okay now that's very important
because the miracle we are proposing is
precisely that since you don't
understand how to compute the deficit
with inclusion we are going to get zero
inclusion and then you will see that the
deficit disappears because the interest
rates from nine and a half will come
down to four four and a half and the
deficit will disappear now then the next
trick is how do you get the inflation
okay that's of course there is an
important trick and that requires for
workers and the unions that they
represent them to understand inflation
illusion okay on their part that is to
understand that what matters is real
wages not nominal wages if you are given
a certain deal wage if we can agree on
the real wage path then you shouldn't
care how much you get nominally and in
particular you can accept zero as long
as the prices were to fall four percent
per year and your real wage you put nice
now we don't need to do that we could
just say let's aim at zero price
inflation and four percent or three or
four percent increase in wages due to
productivity so the trick is to workers
to accept the notion that from now on
they will have in increase determined by
productivity ok except therefore a wage
increase which is no larger when wage
increases correspond to productivity
unit labor cost doesn't change when unit
labor costs doesn't change prices do not
change ok provided the change rate
is maintained or is declining and in the
case of Italy in our program therefore
consists of holding inflation aiming at
zero inflation okay through agreement
with the unions and employers and the
government see the level must do its
part by not raising indirect taxes and
so on and so forth the number of
conditions that must be met have a
compact that aims at zero inflation then
you get as benefits first of all the
vanishing of the dataset and you meet
the master condition by having very low
inflation and very low zero deficit okay
now you do not meet the deficit the debt
to income ratio but that it's a stupid
condition and it's been always said that
nobody is going to look carefully at
that condition is provided you can show
that you are making progress it's
immaterial and of course with a balanced
budget and you would be making progress
toward the name because as the as the
GNP Rises the ratio declines so you
don't even need the surplus just the
growth per se reduces the debt and and
you can go quite a bit that way the
maybe note that the United States came
out of the war of the second world war
with a debt that was 1.4 times income by
the time Reagan became president the
ratio was down to point 38 okay then of
course Reagan quickly reversed things
and didn't quite manage to go back to
where we where he if he had stayed as
president long enough he would have done
it but fortunately you cannot be
president more than twice in this
country so we got rid of him and after
that it seemed in very hard to bring
down the deficit
because
the interest got so large that people
weren't willing to pay the taxes to pay
the interest the Reagan interest
and that made it very difficult to avoid
some deficit okay but Thunder yes
remember he is the representative of the
Daniel between July what you cannot
separate
there is a part of the program I think
we have to answer separate two
definitions one issue is that in effect
the price is determined by Union the
labor cost provided the exchange rate is
maintained okay if the change rate
depreciates then the maintenance of the
unit level cost does not imply that
workers maintain their purchasing power
or that their purchasing power increases
according to productivity all right
because if club club is what they tended
mean by unit labor costs in Italian this
cost of the level up in returnable talk
so I see well you be okay
club and that the terminology was
actually invented at the Bank of Italy
when I was in charge of a model modeling
Italy we invented the word club club
constant means that wages rise as much
as productivity which is the program
okay now that ensures that real wages
are concerned in a closed system because
you can see that in the closed system
club is the reciprocal of the real wage
okay now they essentially if you are in
an open economy then the purchasing
power of wages has two components
purchasing power over your own output
the in domestic output and purchasing
power over the foreign output okay now
if the change depreciates then even
though the purchasing power over your
own output
is concerned the purchasing power of a
foreign output is not constant so
depreciation per se makes you lose makes
the worker lose purchasing power but
that's not the end when you have
depreciation the domestic firms find
that they can sell abroad at the higher
price because their prices fallen went
with the depreciation they are the price
in dollars Falls
so to some extent they try to sell more
in to some extent they raise the marker
but when they get more abroad
particularly if there is high activity
they also get a higher price at home in
part because they are because they have
the choice where to sell okay and in
part because foreigners right are unable
to compete because they get less dollars
per watt the export okay so they have to
raise their prices and that makes it
easy for the domestic people to raise
their prices in other words the
devaluation makes them increases they
the ability of the domestic firm to sell
abroad or or at home okay and some
extent that shows up into higher markup
and higher profits so in that sense you
cannot divide the two but that is
precisely the sense in which it is
essential in a program of this kind to
look at the effect on the foreign
exchange and one of the things we have
in our program is that the foreign
exchange the leader will appreciate so
that the workers will gain in fact more
than the productivity through the
depreciation and that's only fair
because they lost before through the
depreciation okay
at the advantage of firms now over the
next period you're going to have a
reversal firms will be somewhat squeezed
and workers should be earning more okay
now this is happening at the great gun
grid rate because fortunately the
victory of the center-left
has been greeted by the international
market we
great warmth enthusiasm and the lira has
moved since proudiy
will go and elections down to just over
one thousand it was about 160 s move
down to 1015 remarkable think our plan
is being outdated because our program
was to bring it to 1,000 in two years
we'll get there before but that's fine
now probably we don't want to go much
beyond that why because we think that
1000 is a very nice exchange rate
because once this happens we will issue
a new leader will called a heavy lira
which will be worth $1,000 and one mark
okay so a lira would be one mark now
yeah well this is the the currency board
has been mentioned and the trouble is
that that solution in my view is a
mechanical ignorant solution that is it
it's true and if a country doesn't have
a reasonable labor union okay then maybe
what you want to do is to say look I put
myself in a position when I cannot
control the money supply
if you push wages you get unemployment
okay and you do that you tie your hands
I say if you have an intelligent labor
union let's agree on how to do it and
let the money supply be adjusted to the
needs of the economy okay so if the
economy is growing fast we'll need more
money and we don't why do we have to
wait until we import we we get more
reserves and then grow we don't have to
do that so they can't see I mean the
this so-called currency board as you
know this has been adopted this is
essentially the Hongkong system okay but
essentially Hong Kong creates money only
as it gets dollars from the surplus
okay so it's people deposit dollars they
get Hong Kong dollars
one-for-one and there's all kinds of
problems with it I mean in fact right
now Hong Kong has a lot of problem
because the inflation domestic inflation
is appreciably higher than the foreign
inflation so you have all kinds of
problems high interest rates all kinds
of real problems and I think counting on
intelligent unions I think we can do it
and by the way I can say when things
that's very important that the head of
the Union which with which we shall work
surges and Tony is really clear twice
that he is for the zero inflation
program that they will work for it and
it looks for in fact he's he asked the
new president to call them in for
consultation which he hasn't done yet he
said what are you waiting for we are
here ready to work together which
doesn't mean that will be so easy to
reach an agreement because there is a
question of the past
workers have lost some not as much as
they think first of all because the
comparison has to be made see the
comparison the workers make when they
seek we have not so much is between
agreed wages and the cost of living but
actually there are effective wages are
not necessarily as those in agreement
because there are payments above the
agreement okay now if you look at the
actual wage the differential is not so
large but it is still there probably
three percent in two years something
like that but the point is that the
argument we are trying to make is don't
try to recoup the three percent now
because you want if you get a higher
three percent it will show up in higher
prices okay
have an agreement that looks forward and
says from now on I get the
cost-of-living unit plus the benefit of
the declining exchange rate then
everybody better off okay now when of
course of the important consequences of
the zero inflation is the interest rate
will decline roughly by to the extent of
inflation now we have firmly half okay
and interest rates already down to about
ninety when the first load this
inflation was five and interest rates
were about nine they have they can come
down another four or five points okay
that also means that it encourages
investment of course there is inclusion
illusion that is firms should really
tell you that the month the deal cost of
money is the same if they pay for and no
inclusion with the pain and with
inflation but it actually makes it it
well in part because in terms of short
term rates it makes no difference but in
terms of long term rates it does make a
difference because if you don't think
inflation is going to last then
bothering at nine percent it's a bad
thing because eventually you you will
have paid nine when interest rate will
have come down so it does make a
difference what the nominal rate is
so you will have that advantage and of
course essentially by controlling cost
you will be able to maintain the
advantage in terms of exports to be some
loss because as the lien appreciates
then we make it somewhat worst but then
to some extent the appreciation will
correspond to the fact that Italian
inflation is below French or German or
Dutch whatever it is and that Percy
justifies appreciation so now so those
are the fundamental tricks one what is
being proposed in Italy I didn't quite
finish that there is the 7% people who
speak have refused to understand that
that deficit doesn't exist I had we had
an argument
when Italy's most known a financial
specialist who is now representing Italy
in the government of the community
professor Mario Monti who claimed that
no he does not want to make the
adjustment okay we explain why it has to
be made and he said no and I think I
told you that the reason we said no it's
because he thought that if you tell the
Italians they have no deficit they will
create one immediately okay so you must
tell them you are overburdened with
deficit therefore you have to cut down
the expenditure otherwise it's
impossible so an economist must lie in
order to mean to sort of tell falsehood
to people so they behave as he thinks
they should behave I don't believe in
that
if economists say the truth and tell
them that because you have no deficit
bless God and don't get into one okay
that's the thing to do you don't have to
be persuaded by being squashed by the
deficit so
what did it just second let me just
finish this so what are they saying well
I said some say let's not give up
message and some say that next year we
have to do a really big financial
operation so as to cut down the seven to
three percent that means a tax levy tax
and expenditure levy of four percent of
GNP which is a gigantic one hundred
seventy billion it's a gigantic
operation okay
for what in order to create a surplus in
order to balance the budget with the
technicians deficit but really creating
huge a huge surplus increase further the
primary surplus create what is really a
huge surplus okay and as I'll show in a
moment create a real deflation in the
economy and in the end a disaster what
we say is forget the big financial
ladies forget me how do they call the
day I forget the word they use I forget
the word let's use significant
anyway we forget it the big the big
maneuver okay
a strangle a strangled which means
beaten forget the big beating with a
with the rod okay forget it if you do
that you do mean the economy and you
don't need to okay if you can get zero
inflation or just about there you don't
need it now before I go further and show
you essentially the implication of the
alternatives I have to make one comment
why say we say zero inflation program
and we want a program wages has to
maintain unit labor costs stable why
can't you get zero inflation
in 97 yes why not immediately why not in
97
the reason unfortunately is that there
is lags in retail price formation all
right essentially at the detail level
prices depend on what it costs now to
buy that good but to a large extent on
what you paid for it last year okay
essentially the inventories are treated
at cost rather than at reproduction cost
so they try to recoup that by prices not
adjusting dropped from tea and so that
means that during if you try to come
down very fast you end up by creating a
larger spread for the intermediaries for
the retailers and so on which they may
not notice because they don't figure
things right okay
they're probably really are higher but
they may not even notice it so you
cannot do it too fast because if you do
it too fast you end up by increasing
their profits at the expense of the
workers okay see they produce the
manufacturers at the wholesale level
will have no advantage because they
presume we will pass on the unit labor
costs into their prices but it is at the
next stage at the various stages of
services plus the factory is a large
volume of services which are not based
of goods but you know sort of various
kinds of professional service and so on
and so forth where the legs tend to be
more substantial in other words in the
case of labor you can make an agreement
about the wage you cannot do that as
easily with the cleaners with the
lawyers with the doctors and so on and
yeah well you can do it to some extent
with government employees although that
has some problems of its own so we have
to accept a slower pace
and that means that real wages initially
cannot rise very much they can rise some
but there's a limited space until the
ketchup is finished that is until we get
to the point where while we're bringing
them down there is some unavoidable loss
once they are down the loss would
disappear one way of minimizing that
loss would be to get as he says and more
efficient service industry okay that's
one of the great difficulties and I
think any of you that come from the less
advanced countries know the great
problem that the the whole area of
detail is exceedingly inefficient you're
still relying on the family store which
has huge markups because they are very
inefficient they there aren't efficient
stores maybe the supermarket's the
market in the supermarket but as you can
imagine the merchants hit the
supermarket's okay they really are
ruining the country because they are
ruining me and I am the country so they
fight very hard against giving permits
and very hard for all kinds of
ridiculous things which we still have
even in this country namely I was
opening and closing hours stores only
opened at 9:00 o'clock and they must
close at 6:00 okay well why why don't
you let anybody does whatever he wants
okay that's because it's not convenient
for those people that exist so you have
this tremendous stronghold of this class
intermediary class which is large and
controls a lot of the local communities
in an effort to get a more efficient
distribution but there I think is quite
right a lot of the program should be in
pushing through a rapid rationalization
of the distribution system creating
competition if necessary even stores
garment stores or local entity stores I
mean not central government
but local stores that compete and so on
where yes yes yes that's right
well I think that there is a great
problem because the this class of
merchants is very powerful as a this has
enormous influence now where do you live
in Rome yeah and that's nothing I mean
if you go to the South some of the
smaller places there is just very very
hard that's right that's right
I mean you know it's no you're gonna be
careful again distinguish between the
more powerful which simply means it's a
combination of will and the organization
that it takes to make that will into an
action ok there may be a lot of people
who are unhappy better organized ok they
don't put up candidates and things like
that what is the merchants do okay and
you know the merchants in Italy are a
bad class there's no question we have
seen that recently when he gave a real
example of indecent when they invited to
speak at their convention the fascists
the head of the fascist government and
mr. Prodi who is now the President and
mr. Feeny was applauded and when it came
to mr. Prodi they did not let him speak
the hissed and shouted so that he had to
quit without speaking they they were the
merchants had been invited to shout
against mr. Prodi essentially because
the central left is in favor of laws
that will make people pay their taxes
and the merchants do not intend to do
that he won't do whatever is convenient
to them now so you have this problem of
which it is not possible to do things
quickly and there is you have a
trade-off between real wages and
quickness
the only real quick then the real wages
will not rise if you take a little more
time then the reasonable possibility
some margin for your register eyes now
I want to come back a moment to the
following think that the so the key
propositions really are I think I've
told you essentially what is the
foundation and what makes you think that
all this is feasible all right and as
you can see if you follow this program
then in two years
Italy will meet all the requirements for
being in masters priests in three years
because the deficit will come down
gradually as interest rates decline okay
so it's not instantaneous interest rates
we move down with inflation and as
inflation comes down interest come down
and the deficit comes down and then of
course you do have this important
mechanism which already occurred
unfortunately I should have known that
nimmy that as this goes on the exchange
rate appreciates
of course I know that there are
expectations and since people expected
this will happen in fact it happens
quickly and in fact to some extent
interest rates will decline on the
expectation of usual decline
particularly the long rate in the longer
it is still quite high and you know
anybody can figure out that there are
huge capital gains to be made if you buy
issues which were still made 3-4 months
ago with a 12 percent coupon okay if the
interest rate comes down to long-term
rate comes down to five these are tenure
issues the price will appreciate it
enormously
now it may appreciate enormously in the
expectation that it will be high later
and therefore some of these things may
occur faster then you would think if you
didn't allow for people believing that
these things will happen this will all
happen to make it to make it happen all
will help to make it happen now there is
I think important precedents to justify
this expectation because one
the key issues here is the the issue of
interest rate behavior and relation
between price between wage and prices
okay
now on this connection we have first
done some interesting experiments first
let me say this that during the one of
the great wonders of the period that
follows the devaluation was the behavior
of inflation I can find this yes you
have all seen now see I think that
Elizabeth made the slide of me that is
the cover sheet of the book but that's
not what I'm looking for
okay now one of the great wonders of the
inflation of the period of in which the
lira was depreciated was the following
when the lira went was pushed out of the
EMS it lost initially about 20% and then
over the rest of the year as explained
and the Rubies loaded on bush influence
brooded on bush by the way is a
miserable man because they had sorrows
and they didn't tell me so he didn't
tell me so he's a miserable man but
nonetheless he is a miserable genius and
has explained to him he pushed the Bank
of Italy to let exchange go not try to
get back into the MS keep interest rates
low latex they changed appreciate and it
depreciated up to about 30% reach the
peak about 30% from below 700 to 1000
now of course at that point it makes a
difference whether you calculate the
lira when you look at the changes of
that magnitude you'll get some more
different answers if you look at the
lira mark on the mark lira but anyway
that's roughly 30% and the great amazing
thing is that the behavior of completion
when that happened inflation a graph
with inflation is 3/8 can you see that
c8 at the bottom right okay
okay now you have there
one dark having dark line okay
that line is what actually happened and
as you can see inflation up to 94
inflation kept declining in the face of
the thirty percent devaluation I was an
absolutely amazing experience okay
it eventually picked up again but that
is because champey was replaced by
Berlusconi and since he was an incapable
man
he quickly produced inflation again okay
I mean it as a head of the government
and then as the opposition okay who was
blackmailing the country that's how he
managed to get that but you can see that
up to his longest champy was there they
inclusion decline and if we had
quarterly data well actually can see
directly the one interesting question
that we have asked ourselves is why has
that happened how is it possible
how could one achieve this result okay
now the standard explanations are that
sort of an important explanation is that
to some extent the devaluation of 92 and
the 93 was a very weak here in the world
markets therefore on the one hand raw
material imports because raw material
prices were falling in the world they
didn't rise too much in liras okay
relative to what we do in abroad a lot
more but not much more
and the the don't competitive market is
industrial production and son or the go
ballistic kind of goods the foreign
firms were pressed for markets because
they were losing markets all over
decided that rather than take advantage
and rather than sort of keeping their
prices constant okay
which would have mean a higher prices in
Lyra that they would try to compete with
the Italian films by cutting their price
so they essentially cut their export
prices in Marx okay which meant that the
Italian prices rose less and then in
turn put pressure on the Italian firms
not to these prices too much but this
combination of things was certainly one
important element now in addition to
that there was domestic contraction in
92 and 93 okay explain that essentially
that domestic contraction was the
combination in 93 was the combination of
the shock of the valuation Italians are
prized I would say pretty proud people
sometimes not reasonably so just like
the Spaniards or whatever this or the
Greek and they took very badly the
devaluation carton and something
demeaning that they had to devalue 30%
okay and it took time to understand and
that's what made their fortune but that
was a source of depression and on top of
that the Amato in champey government the
good government beat them in terms of
taxes really hard in the raise taxes and
they made a big step which moved
essentially the real deficit to zero the
corrected deficit came close to zero
already then there are only got even
more so but already very close to zero
through this very sharp rises in taxes
that reduce consumption and discourage
people and put them in a very depressed
mood and so you had then
our consumption okay and lower
investment because the activity was low
so the only thing that was pushing was
exports because the devaluation put them
in a position to increase exports and
they rose quite fast but on the whole
there was a contraction and that
presumably may have helped in holding
prices down but of course there was
another element and that was that in
1932 for the first time labour agreed to
a nominal wage contract that in 1993 was
confirmed by mister Champy and there was
a specific arrangement about a plan for
prices and wage inflation
both of which were supposed to decline
over the next three years okay
four and a half in 96 and sorry 95 three
and a half in 96 and two and a half in
97 was the problem I personally told Mr
champy that that program was inadequate
it should have been two one zero
okay well before I got there it was even
higher and he did cut it down with some
effort was able to persuade him to cut
some but still it was better than
nothing okay and the wages were supposed
to behave accordingly allowed with
productivity to some extent now now the
interesting question is which of these
or and then on top of that there was the
Amato I mean the web dis fiscal laws
okay which by reducing income
contributed to a depressed economy and
therefore contributed to lower prices so
the question is what did what so to try
to answer this question we have made
three simulations the results of which
are shown here in the first is the
following a group of people and
particularly I think at the Bank of
Italy
said that the reason why inclusion was
still for the half of three and a half
is because we had the value in other
words with the devaluation we had low
inflation without evaluation would have
been even lower okay
why because without I mean without that
there would not have been higher import
prices the devaluation increased import
prices and domestic prices - to some
extent so they said if you just had
forgotten you just had and they don't
say how if you just that somehow managed
to weather the storm and not the value
or maybe fifteen percent as they first
thought but no more you would receive
yourself all the trouble now it turns
out that so one of these simulations see
the first one the heavy line says
Estonia that means history that's the
actual history so underneath that here
Lyra windows me that is keeping the lira
in this may possibly fifteen percent
lower but takes exchange okay so you got
in the new low rate of course they don't
tell us how you do it because it had
Bank of Italy tried that and was that
successful that is the investors didn't
believe it therefore they kept pulling
out money and then the Bank of Italy
threw in a lot of reserves and then at
the end gave up and in fact they won
crime that has been claimed by mr.
Berlusconi when he attacked mister
Champy had been Prime Minister before
him is that his wasted billions in
trying to defend the lira when he
shouldn't and maybe is right to some
extent mr. champion was perhaps
conventional central bankers he hate to
yield to speculation they always hope to
beat the speculators and give them big
losses
so he tried hard anyway he didn't
succeed so to this simulation tells you
what would have happen if you somehow
had managed to put together enough
reserves to throw into the breach so as
to maintain the 15% and then after that
you had to keep very high interest rates
to attract a balloon okay so you really
would have had to continue with the 15%
or so interest rates that prevailed as
the Bank of Italy tried to bring back
the cabin 15 20 % did reach 20% now in
that situation of course it is true that
they you get the result which is shown
by the broken line okay it is true that
inflation would have been lower okay if
you somehow couldn't maintain the change
rate you would have avoided the
valuation inflation would have been
lower
however at what cost well the cost you
can see in remaining graphs
first they in terms of the GNP you do
get a depressed level of the GNP even
though in 94 for the complicated reason
it's a little higher but the rest in
slower okay except in 94 it is always a
pressure below and accumulates to
something like 4% law so you would have
to sacrifice output and employment okay
Italy had plenty of unemployment that
policy would have led to more
unemployment this shows what it does to
investment you have high interest rates
therefore Lord investments okay and so
on and of course the worst part is in
terms of the balance of payments the
balance mean you would not have had the
huge increase in exports therefore the
balance would have remained negative and
you've been human
not that okay which presumably at some
point for the force you do the value
anyway so and best it could have been a
transitory policy and would have been
pretty bad for the country and the next
thing we tried was to see suppose you
had everything else equal you know you
are out of this million zone but let's
take out the amount of tax measure okay
now he essentially without going to
details what that does is actually to
somewhat reduce employment because the
drain from the economy would have reduce
the demand so in terms of output you
find that the Amato maneuver would have
in other ways that without the amount of
maneuver the output is higher and the
right motor maneuver is is the thin line
and though I guess that the reason is I
think essentially that you might have
saved spare yourself the great deflation
of 93 I remember and remember exactly
how that works
but in in terms of inflation the Amato
maneuver
doesn't really make too much difference
now the last that is the broken line
okay now in terms of inflation you get a
lower rate of inflation because the the
amount of maneuver is a deflation
maneuver to get less inflation but you
get the bad consequences in terms of
output and then the last one is
essentially the effect of the labor and
it shows what would have happen without
the labor agreement
and the results are dramatic the top
line is the rate of inflation
they wouldn't exist without the Accord
and you can see that while inflation
decline it would have increased
substantially cut into a high level a
lot of harm to the government deficit
and so on and so forth and we conclude
the century
that the fundamental thing that worked
is the agreement the labor agreement
there was the fundamental anchor that
permitted the low rate of inflation so
that means that we know if we can get
labor and the rest to work together and
we can maintain the exchange rate stable
then we really have a good handle on
inflation so that's important to
understand what works and what doesn't
now when you look at of course the whole
history you've got to remember this
particular episode that in the spring of
93 and in Ciampi come in the spring of
93 and he contributed to the lowering of
inflation okay as long as it was there
he then left and the dramatic effect of
mr. well the contrast between champy and
the next government is in the graph
which I hope I can find here which shows
two things the behavior of inflation the
behavior of exchange rates and the
behavior of interest rates okay
traumatic thing is that under champion
the differential between the Italian
lira and the German mark which measures
the trust of investments in lira
denominated instruments okay how much
they believe the government would pay
and to what extent they believed
exchange rate will not
generate it's a major measure that under
champion cannot find any meat he went
they premium went from about five and a
half to two and a half in a little over
here now
Italian interest rate okay I determined
by what fundamentally you live in the
country now which is totally open
capital movements so when I speak of
investors
trusting the government or not I'm speak
primarily of Italian investors it's not
mr. Soros State aniele's they either
trust the government and keep the money
there or don't and just pull out their
money okay and when of course people
want to move the capital out what
happens well as you understand if you
don't have a fixed exchanges if you have
fixed exchange rate and capital moves
out then the central bank pays our
reserves in the dollars you know you $1
here is the lawless it take them out as
long as I have reserved at some point I
have no more and then I have to devalue
which happened in 1952 but when you
don't have that when Camila wants to
move see there's only one way capital as
against reserves really moves and that
is by moving goods so in the long run
the only way you can move capital is by
increasing than their exports what
happens the short run well I want to
sell the earth and nobody wants to buy
them I won't buy Marx and nobody wants
to sell them well the leader goes down
you get sharp depreciation attacks now
under mister Champy the exchange rate
improved somewhat not romantically but
improved somewhat nor was it desirable
for it to move too much because the
export surplus was essential to the
maintenance of the Italian development
but the decline in the risk premium
showed up in decline in interest rate
because Italian interest rates in an
open market are
German interest rates okay mother we've
step one leg you remember the
fundamental principle of interest rate
parity right that interest rate
differentials is essentially compensated
by depreciation that is if a country has
a higher interest than another it is
because it's country is going to
depreciate because the real return to a
German investing lira is the literally
turn minus the rate of depreciation of
the lira okay so fundamentally you have
interest differentials equal exchange
rate differential but what about
exchange rate differential you know
about purchasing power parity and the
purchasing power parity exchange rate
differential is the differential in the
relevant region so fundamentally Italian
interest rates the real Italian rates
are equal to real German rates plus this
premium or nominal rates are equal to
German nominal rates - remembers
inflation plus it an inflation now as
the inflation was coming down but mostly
as the risk premium came down enormously
interest rates went came down about five
percentage points in little over a year
okay the government deficit improved and
the investment were helped and so on and
so forth so there was a dramatic effect
of mr. champion the moment he left
everything began moving rivers exchange
rate began to depreciate again modestly
interest rates went up rather quickly
back and by the end of the British
colony government they were close to
where is the champion left and whatever
he didn't do and why did that happen
well because the rest of the world had
no confidence in champion was an
exceptional man it was the former
government Bank of Italy with an
international
very well-known worked many
international organizations he was
trusted mr. Berlusconi you know there
was no reason to trust him he had to
show well he began by not paying any
attention to the finances he did not
prepare the first financial plan in time
he led to months go by because he was
busy with capturing the tibia
televisions he owned he had a monopoly
in the private sector and now he had the
government televisions under his wing so
he took care of changing all the people
so to be his people was so busy doing
that paid no attention to what was
important so even though as he came to
power I wrote an article him to clear
the nasarah mr. Berlusconi the main
thing you need to worry about is give
confidence to further investors continue
the tight fiscal position he came in
promising tax cuts and the like
and he proceeded to do it much of that
was wrong because even though in some
cases it was justified as incentives
they were stupid incentives for Italy
essentially you got an incentive if you
hire more people but you know how
Italians are they took the firm divide
in half okay and from the old firm they
like they set out a certain number and
then they were taken by the new firm and
the new firms of course was creating
employment
therefore they got the benefit okay and
the same thing happened with incentive
to invest where all kinds of dirty
tricks of culture there was a lot of
money wasted in these programs anyway
the limit was reached of course as I
told you when Berlusconi was pushed out
of the government he wanted immediate
elections he said I want elections in
spring and the President of the Republic
told him go to Parliament because I
don't control elections Parliament dance
tell them to dissolve themselves then we
will have elections and he could not
persuade Parliament he decided to
boycott
the country to put pressure on
Parliament by ruining the country so he
decided to vote against the financial
law that was proposed by the government
succeeded him a law which was absolutely
essential because his own financial law
had been inadequate okay when the world
saw that half the country was willing to
ruin the country to have its way well
everybody took the money out including I
little whatever head I took out okay I
had just a deposit with the bank anyway
the lira jumped from about a thousand
when Berlusconi came in to 1280 okay now
at that point because the tragedy was
that the inflation they devaluation of
the lira created inflation through the
two routes I mentioned in the foreign
goods were more expensive and Italian
firms were able to charge higher prices
the mark-up knows the wages kept on
their path as a greed remarkably sure
but prices did not leave anyway the
plane was four and a half three and a
half two and a half as long as champy
was there it was four and a half and it
was three and a half to the middle to
the time he left
inflation was down to three and a half I
think you might be able to see it from
the graph but anyway was down to exactly
three and a half
as soon as middle school he took over
with the devaluation the inflation went
up again so the reason the whole thing
failed is not that the idea of a pact
was wrong it's not that you cannot have
a pact it's only that if for the back to
work and to be fair you must avoid
evaluations you must avoid evaluations
we shall see the special teacher is
Italy it had many devaluations but in
the past they were essentially due to
labor pushing for high
nominal wages which eventually made the
Italian product non-competitive led to
financial crisis and to devaluation but
this time the devaluation had nothing to
do with wages wages were perfectly well
behaved unit labour cost was well
behaved in the devaluation only had with
capital invested in Italy by Italians
and foreigners losing confidence in the
country and trying to get the money out
so that has created a period of Clayton
easiness because the workers were losing
and getting more and more questionable
as to whether you ever wanted to enter
in another agreement like that okay look
us stupid people like the one I debated
on TV claim that if we had had escalator
clauses that wouldn't happen and that's
because he's an idiot he doesn't
understand that and I tried to explain
to him and you know what he did he
laughed and I was explaining X trying to
explain - I didn't see him but I'm told
that's what he did I tried to explain to
him that if we had heavy escalator
clauses we have had inflation and the
same loss of purchasing power only on an
inflation is path because the inflation
is unavoidable when you devalue right
when you devalue foreign goods cost more
okay and if you try to index your
productivity having not changed you try
to keep up with foreign prices costs go
up prices go up and so you get inflation
and then we just have to go up to catch
up so there's nothing you can do the
workers do lose whenever there is a
devaluation of that magnitude so since
then the change leaders move back and
thanks God has been a tremendous last
step when mr. Prodi was bound elections
now we are essentially working with that
principle of getting down back their
growth to get the workers to believe
that will not have anymore the
valuations okay now it's not
unfortunately
entirely simple because you have people
like this
mr. Bertie naughty who is the head of a
nine percent group that commands nine
percent of the votes which is extreme
left he really is a communist and is a
stupid and ignorant as the Communists
are in economics affairs
you know communists may have certain
virtues in some manner but they never
understood economics very much and as
you can see from Russia and he keeps
insisting that we should have escalator
clauses hi and the head of the Union say
we do not want escalator clauses we want
to negotiate wages we don't want to have
any mechanical device unfortunately the
government does not have a majority
without this splinter group so there is
some question as to whether they are
going to be able to prevent another
scare it's not it's not entirely
guaranteed you know to some extent it
will depend on whether mr. 30-knot he
can be persuaded you know I kept telling
him that the reason workers lost is not
because of the lack of escalator clauses
is because he voted with the extreme
right against the financial law so it's
his fault is the work as a were self but
and I turn from now on when you vote
remember what effect this will have on
the change rate if you love workers
don't vote in the way they will produce
devaluation with the understand now is
too stupid I'm afraid I don't know I
don't even know whether he's stupid or
not I'm just playing stupid and maybe he
can be persuaded in an event you have a
general idea of how this thing can work
it does a lie by the way they manifest
the association of manufacturers in
general entrepreneurs and groups large
and small here might I have present here
my nephew Enrico Modigliani who was the
president of one of the local units of
the young manufacturers right
the small enterprises I'm sorry yes yes
the association of manufacturers or
small enterprises anyway in general
these groups are in favor of the program
okay they want to see it work because
for them it means on the one hand lower
interest rate opportunities to expand
maintaining their market to some extent
some squeeze on profits but not to
cities and the so there is a will of I
think a substantial group of those that
matter and if they stick to something
like this I think Italy can't come out
so that in two to three years it will
meet all the requirement of mass which
that matter and we probably the first
country to meet those requirements
because it will have low inflation and
lower deficits than any other country
and with the entry the lower interest
rates can be assured because by the time
Italy is a member of the pack right
eternal interest rates cannot be higher
than German interest rate you see you
have this great paradox then when Italy
was pushed out of the common market the
idea was that they might now be free to
have lower interest rates because the
change is no longer being pegged you
could have felt lower interest rates at
the cost of devaluation and what
happened in fact is that interest rate
still systematically higher why because
of this terrible risk premium the change
risk okay and so that some of it was in
force in Plzen differential evenly kept
somewhat higher inflation rate but by
the middle of this period actually the
Germans weren't even higher inflation so
there wasn't always one direction but
some some of it was in the inflation
differential but much of it was the risk
premium
due to the change late and as I said we
know that it is due to the change rates
because when the government of Italy
issues bonds denominated in dollars or
marks they differential instead of being
five hundred percent that point is
between point three and point for
between 30 and 40 so the risk of the
country as such the risk of the
government solvency is not regarded as
large it is simply that if you invest in
Italy you're subject to the great risk
that Berlusconi will create another jump
in interest rate in exchange rate and
then you lose your shirt okay because
you you gain two percent on the interest
rate but you lose in one month at the
rate of 20 percent per year about 30
percent per year so it is that exchange
risk that says I'm not going to buy
Italian denominated instruments whether
I am Italian or French makes no
difference is an Italian I'm not going
to invest in them in Italian instrument
because when I think of what I could
have in dollars okay if there is a
depreciation I would rather be in
dollars so essentially that differential
comes from the fear of depreciation of
the children once you are in and you got
texture changes your rate should be
within 30 or 40 basis points of the rest
and you know by that time with the
Italian miracle have you been completed
maybe even the 30 point would disappear
you've shown what you've been able to do
I think you deserve some credit for that
so I would think that the problem of the
deficit is cured and in fact in a year
of - there'll be a surplus because this
huge primary surplus is not needed once
interest rates are down to 4% it's not
needed and so there will be finally a
time where they'll be able to cut taxes
okay and spend more
on important programs including training
programs and the like which are very
much lacking in Italy and of course
Italy still has a huge problem which is
the south okay
unemployment in the south is gigantic
then inside I think what I call the
forget who's low I think but the Sun is
law that says that in Italy in every
region women's employment unemployment
is twice net of men okay so you start
from the north unemployment of men four
percent women eight percent then you
take that and multiply it by one and a
half and you get unemployment in this in
the center so in the center for becomes
I think six that's right I think more
than that about ten yes women the double
then you get to the south and you get
thirty percent or 25 percent among men
and among women twice as much okay now
that problem is still there and that
problem is going to be a hard one to
solve okay because it really made
complex by many many problems and the
unfortunate thing is that in the South
people wait without working until they
can get a post office job the post of
the job is bliss right if you get a post
office job you don't work too much you
get a nice pension with your attire and
you can start your pension at 55 that's
a little changed but has been using your
hair is part of the Italian scandals is
the pension system which by the way has
been also almost fixed not quite but
huge step forward has been made by mr.
Dini and the unions that have worked
together so you know in many ways that
is a sign of maturity that it's very
very encouraging and I think that maybe
before my time is gone Italy will be the
first of the class
[Applause]